whether they were burnt house after
multiple Seasons or killed off to make
room for another actor these sci-fi
Stars left their most popular shows for
all kinds of reasons as FBI agents Fox
Mulder and Dana Scully played by David
Duchovny and Jillian Anderson cycle
mysterious cases involving supernatural
phenomena on the X-Files molder always
assumes a paranormal link while Scully
takes a more skeptical approach but
after dakovny chose to leave the series
at the end of season 7 The Show just
wasn't the same in a statement released
after the news of his departure broke
dakovny said as much as I love the show
I think for me this will be the end I
always thought five years was enough
seven years is definitely enough the
company's contract was officially up at
the end of the seventh season and rather
than renewing it he decided to leave
another Factor also prompted him to say
goodbye however the kovney was also
stuck in a legal battle with Fox over
syndication Revenue as he felt Fox was
taking in Greater profits from reruns
while reducing his own earnings from
royalties sounds like a motive the
original series continued on for two
more seasons with dakovny making only
occasional appearances however he did
return to his leading role in the 10th
and 11th Seasons which aired in 2016 and
2018 well after the initial run had
wrapped up in the mid-2000s there might
not have been any better show than last
but polarizing sci-fi survivalist
Thriller more the show saw plenty of
characters come and go over the course
of his lengthy run numerous
controversial as Mr Echo a drug dealer
and Thug turned priest played by Adam
Wale akanoye agbaje introduced to the
start of the second season he was killed
off early in season three though many
fans have argued about how little of
loss was well planned there seems to be
other reasons for akanoye agbaje's
departure as he unexpectedly asked out
of the series before the season had
wrapped up according to producer Colton
Coos akanoye yakbaje never felt
comfortable in Hawaii but he had moved
to shoot the series a fact not helps by
his arrest by local police that landed
in jail Jews told USA Today Hawaii was
not his bag real life intervened and
forced us to end the Arc of that
character much sooner than we would have
liked in 2010 akanoye agbaje was said to
have been offered at cameo in the series
epic finale where he would have returned
as a faithful Mr Echo but according to E
online he turned it down reportedly due
to a pay disputes as the actor was said
to have been looking for far more than
he was offered
I am not sorry for this
I am proud of this
the first Star Wars series on Disney
plus samandalorian Stars Pedro Pascal
behind that iconic mask there's plenty
of familiar faces in the supposing cast
as well including former MMA fighter
Gina Carano but not long after the
show's second season concluded it was
announced that Carano was out and it was
no secret as to why according to thr R
rumors that Disney was looking to wax
the actress began circulating after she
made a series of controversial social
media posts regarding multiple
polarizing topics from comments on the
covered vaccines to vote a fraud in the
2020 United States presidential election
Toronto did not keep her thoughts to
herself the final straw was so
anti-semitic posts in which she compared
the experience of conservatives to the
suffering of Jewish people during the
Holocaust in response to Growing calls
for a dismissal among the public led by
the hashtag fire Gina Carano Disney was
forced to issue a statement the company
said that she wasn't in the contract
that she wouldn't be continuing in the
series and that they can her online
comments the release read a social media
posts denigrating People based on their
cultural and religious identities are
abhorrent and unacceptable
Willa Holland was a child actress who
grew up amid the hustle and bustle of
Hollywood thanks to her family roads
since her ex-stepfather is Scarface
director Brian De Palmer in the 2000s
she starred in two of the hottest teen
dramas the OC and Gossip Girl before
graduating to Super heroics in the CW's
Arrow there she starred as Oliver
Queen's upstart younger sister Thea who
eventually trains to become a vigilante
herself she ultimately takes on the
super identity of Speedy and becomes
Green Arrow's partner starring for six
seasons in the hit series Holland was a
stalwart of the main cast and an
integral part of Arrow's universe but in
the middle of season 6 audiences were
left stunned when Speedy set off on her
own mission with boyfriend Roy Harper
the hero known as Arsenal this wasn't
just a creative way for the writers to
shake up the status quo in the lead-up
to the final two seasons but an exit
orchestrated by Holland herself producer
and series co-creator Marca Guggenheim
told Entertainment Weekly season 6 is
the end of her contract going into to
season six with all of us knowing it was
the end of her contract Willa expressed
the desire to move on
this version of myself
whoever she is the decision was made not
to kill off the character though us
producers had a fondness for both speedy
and Holland sure enough Holland returned
for a handful of guest appearances over
the final seasons for three seasons Matt
Smith took on the role of the doctor and
Doctor Who head writer and executive
producer Stephen Moffat was very
impressed by Smith from the beginning
after seeing him act he knew that Smith
was a perfect choice to play the 11th
doctor but ultimately Smith became too
burned out by the demands of the role he
told The Hollywood Reporter I'd always
talked about leaving after the 50th
Anniversary it's a very intense process
to play the doctor the line learning is
really hard and you have to live away
from home for 9 or 10 months a year I
love the show and it wasn't an easy
choice to come to but it's the right
time so what now doctor well time to get
cracking dogs
however it seems that Smith now has
mixed feelings about his eventual
decision to leave as he has stated that
he wished he could have spent more time
working with his talented co-star Jenna
Coleman debuting in 1993 Terry Farrell
portrayed John C A Dax in Star Trek Deep
Space Nine before the character was
killed off in the season 6 finale to the
dismay of many she'd been a stalwart
series regular was married to a fellow
main character andal's best friend to
the show's Captain while fans may have
been blindsided fraud has been more than
open about her exit from the series over
the years in a 2011 chat with Trek movie
Farrell said she was feeding some
burnouts after a six-year run she
explained I was just really tired I was
tired of waking up at four in the
morning I was tired of all that minutia
at the same time her contract was up and
she was receiving interest elsewhere
around Hollywood she decided to
renegotiate for Less screen time as she
told Trek today I did suggest in the
wake of that I could be recurring not
being every episode instead her chill
symbians got a new body in the form of
Nicole de Boer in the 2018 documentary
what we left behind Farrell was more
candid describing how she had felt
disrespected by producers she said the
last season when I was told by one of
the producers that I was really lucky to
be there and I really should sign the
next contract because if I weren't there
on the set I'd be at Kmart that was the
last straw for me frowell eventually
landed a lead role in the NBC series
Becca in 1998. in the late 90s actor
Joey O'Connell starred in sliders a cult
favorite that's better than you probably
remember but after its third season the
show mood from Fox to the Sci-Fi channel
and in a 1998 interview in the Chicago
Tribune the actor expressed excitement
about the New Direction saying it's
great to be on the Sci-Fi channel
because we can cater to a more
intelligent audience but says O'Connell
recalled in a 2016 interview with Yahoo
things didn't turn out the way he'd
hoped instead of the show using effects
to explore parallel worlds in unique
ways O'Connell thought sliders have
become too focused on action and
fighting his displeasure with the show's
altered tone coincided with the
exploration of his contract and as a
result the actor felt that it was the
right time to step away explaining I had
learned all that I was going to learn
from the show after four seasons and I
decided to leave when my contract was up
I was hoping that they would go on with
my brother who joined the cast in season
four they got pretty mad and decided to
reboot the whole thing and blow it up
if I'm ready for all that
audiences seem to love live-action
adaptations of popular young adult
sci-fi novel series and the 100 is one
of the biggest on the small screen
running for Seven Seasons it launched on
the CW in 2014 and centered on a group
of people who come back to earth almost
100 years after leaving in the wake of
nuclear Armageddon despite its sprawling
Ensemble casts only three actors starred
in all seven seasons Ricky Whittle
though could have made it four whereas
not for us leaving the show inexplicably
during the third season his character
ended up being killed off in an
eye-popping twist the real Revelation
came in the aftermath of his departure
when whistle revealed behind the scenes
turmoil in an interview with AfterBuzz
TV he explained that it was his choice
to leave the show and claimed that there
was serious beef between him and the
series showrunner Jason Rothenberg
Whittle said he was professionally
bullying me cutting out all the
storyline that I was supposed to be
doing cutting lines cutting everything
else trying to make my character and
myself as insignificant as possible to
the point where it was starting to get
me down to get across just how bad
things were between them Whittle added
if this was in the playgrounds it would
have got physical but I'm an adult and
violence isn't going to solve anything
after joining the long-running British
sci-fi smash Doctor Who in the titular
role Christopher Eccleston found the
famous part to be more trouble than it
was worth he ended up leaving the show
after only one season leaving fans
wondering why ecclestone explained
during a panel discussion at New York
Comic-Con in 2019 I left only because of
those three individuals and the way they
were running the show I loved playing
the character I felt I was going to play
the doctor my way and I wasn't going to
get involved with those politics and
that wasn't workable so off I went
ecclestone even admitted that the three
individuals he had professional
conflicts were with the showrunner
producer and co-producer of the show he
also faced other obstacles while playing
the doctor he struggled with an eating
disorder while filming and he felt he
was treated unfairly by the media
eventually he reached the point where he
felt that staying in the role was no
longer in his best interests before
joining the cast of Star Trek the Next
Generation is Wesley Crusher Will
Wheaton had already made a name for
himself with roles in films like Stand
By Me playing Crusher represented a
career boost for winter in but after a
few seasons he decided to leave to
pursue other aspirations in Hollywood
Wheaton explained during a panel
discussion at the Calgary comic and
Entertainment Expo in 2012. initially I
thought it was a really smart business
career move in some ways it was and in
more ways it wasn't what I wasn't
prepared for was how much I was going to
miss the people on this stage he
admitted that he didn't make much of an
effort to stay in touch with the rest of
the cast after making his exit and
eventually he felt embarrassed about his
decision to leave the show he added I
just felt really ashamed of myself I
felt like I just couldn't go to the set
I felt like I couldn't look them in the
eye and that I couldn't invite them to
my wedding fortunately years later he
was able to reconnect with his former
co-stars and unsurprisingly they had no
hard feelings towards him for leaving
the show on the military science fiction
series Stargate SG-1 Don S Davis played
George Hammond who runs a military base
Stargate command Hammond is a Stern
straight laced guy who genuinely cares
about the people under his watch his
characterization possible inspired by
Davis's own experiences in the military
Davis eventually admitted that he had to
leave Stargate earlier than he had
intended why did he have to quit he was
dealing with multiple health problems
that made it very difficult for him to
continue acting David stated that the
show Runners were always willing to work
around her surgeries doctor's
appointments and others scheduling
conflicts but eventually he simply
couldn't keep pushing ahead with work
Davis explained in an interview with the
gate's World Stargate stood by me they
made sure that there was nothing that I
was asked to do that might Put Me In
Harm's Way But there comes a time where
you really can't if you're in my
condition I'm a heart patient I'm a
diabetic I've got other minor problems
and there's really time to slow down
sadly Davis passed away after suffering
a heart attack in 2008. Star Trek is one
of the most well-known sci-fi franchises
of all time but not every actor involved
to satisfy with their character's Arc
Denise Crosby who played security Chief
Tasha ya in Star Trek the Next
Generation didn't think that the writers
gave her enough interesting material to
work with over time Crosby became more
and more frustrated with the way Tasha
ya was portrayed as she started to feel
like more of a prop than an actress she
has stated that out of all the
characters she has played Tasha was the
one she held nearest to her heart but
eventually she realized that she would
never be able to develop the character
further Crosby explained in a 1996
interview with star trek.com I want
wanted to leave as I was struggling with
not being able to do much with the
character I had all these ideas and
couldn't do them I was just stage
dressing I chose to leave instead of
just being satisfied with that I've
never regretted my decision
I'm not supposed to be here sir the
superhero Sci-Fi show Misfits was an
unexpected hit in the United Kingdom and
helped to launch the careers of several
Rising Stars including Robert Sheehan
and misfits she and starred as Nathan
young a man who realizes that he is a
model when he wakes up in his own coffin
but after an exciting character Rock
Sheen decided to quit while he was ahead
and take his career in a New Direction
after two seasons she and told Digital
Spy I was absolutely quite happy about
when I went off it seems like a
no-brainer at the time because I was
just a Restless fella who was trying to
go off and do as much different stuff as
possible I'd done two good Summers with
that show Summers was wildly impatient
to do other stuff it turned out to be a
good career move proving that Misfits
opened up doors for him after his
departure she and landed a regular role
as Darren on love hate and more recently
the role of fun favorite Klaus
Hargreaves on the Umbrella Academy Corey
Namek ended up Landing apart on Stargate
sg1 in an unexpected way Michael Shanks
would played Daniel Jackson left the
show after season five and the writers
didn't want to leave a void in the SG-1
team nemec happened to be auditioning
for another role when he bumped into the
casting team for Stargate SG-1 they
thought he seemed like the perfect fit
to play Jonas Quinn a new character they
would be adding to the show they make
loved working on Stargate and even got
to pitch ideas for different episodes
eventually shank was able to come back
for another season nemec hope to stay on
board too but the writers decided it was
time for Jonas Quinn to go when that's
why he was written off the show nemec
admitted that he didn't know why the
writers couldn't have simply
Incorporated both his character and
Michael Shanks into the storyline
however he suspected that budget
limitations may have been a major factor
in the decision
when Star Trek Voyager first launched
the featured several new alien
characters whose presence helped set the
show apart from previous spin-offs this
included the duo of quirky Kook neelix
and the childlike cares the latter of
whom was played by actress Jennifer lean
in season 4 a new cast member joined the
fun favorite former Borg drone seven of
nine played by Joey Ryan and it's no
coincidence that her arrival coincided
with lean's departure series producer
Jerry Taylor said in a DVD special
feature the studio felt that we had too
many characters because seven of nine
was going to join the regular cast
someone had to go lean drew the Short
Straw though it wasn't entirely a random
Choice Ryan and Braga told an audience
at the 2014 Vegas con to my recollection
it was a creative decision and it was a
failure of imagination on the writer's
part we were running out of things to do
with cares still the series didn't say
goodbye forever as kez returned for the
season 6 episode Fury that episode
helped wrap up the long-running story of
the characters abbreviated life cycle
and gave her fitting send-off than she'd
seen in season 4's the gift
there are two generations of Richard
Dean Anderson ferns the first known for
his role as a crafty do-gooder MacGyver
whose titular series made him an 80s
icon but there's another generation of
fans who know him best for his role as
Jack O'Neill in Stargate sg1 Anderson
had taken over the role from action icon
Kurt Russell it starred in the film the
show had been adapted from but he found
a way to make it his own unfortunately
following the show's eighth season
Anderson departed and it was never the
same so why did he leave apparently it
all came down to priorities in 1998
Anderson and his partner April a prose
had a child and by 2004 Anderson was
feeling the pull of family in 2018
gateworld.com covered his appearance of
Fan Expo Canada where they discussed his
exit from the show citing his desire to
spend more time with his wife and
daughter more than a decade after
leaving the series though Anderson said
he would have no problems with the
notion of returning to the role with
concrete limitations he told fans at the
event as far as punching the clock and
going to work I wouldn't mind doing a
mini series of some kind something that
had a clear beginning and end I would do
something along those lines
in 2021 a new version of Superman hit
the small screen with Superman and Lois
an action adventure series that sees a
famous comic book couple raising a pair
of teenagers Jordan Elsas and Alex
garfin played Clark Kent's Sons Jonathan
and Jordan following the first two
seasons however Elsas made a surprise
announcement that he would be leaving
the series and a report in deadline
mentioned sources claiming that Elsas
was dealing with personal issues the
actors sat down with a rap about a week
later to clear the air revealing a
struggle with his mental health he said
it's sad it's a real shame I know that I
was pumped for season three for sure but
what are you gonna do anyway mental
health is definitely 100 priority it's
Pinnacle it's got to take precedence and
mine has been it's been rough though
Elsas didn't go any further into his
experience it sounds like he was
thinking about leaving Hollywood
altogether he elaborated I need some
time to myself I'm still debating
whether I'm even going to add for a
while
sadly Star Trek is still losing stars to
this day with Star Trek Discovery
abandoning actor shahzad Latif after
just two seasons Marla's co-stars Jason
Isaacs and Michelle yeoh were never
intended to last very long the chief's
situation was something a bit different
in the first season Latif Stardust
Lieutenant Ash Tyler while his door roll
is a mysterious Klingon Vogue was kept a
tightly guided secret after all it sat
at the center of the season's major plot
twist but he returned in season 2 as
Tyler who'd abandoned his Klingon
identity and began a romantic
relationship with series lead Michael
Burnham but the character surprising
goodbye in the season 2 finale leaving
to head up the covert intelligence
agency known as section 31. this isn't a
case of Latif requesting off of the
series though quite the opposite in fact
in a 2022 interview the actor revealed
just what happened according to a report
from Trek movie Producers have been
planning a spin-off series focused on
section 31 to Star Latif alongside
Superstar Michelle yeoh but because of
Yo's limited availability see the series
has yet to get off the ground leaving
Latif in limbo
you understand what I'm saying
a Meola meme played copious on the first
season of sense8 but fans were this
surprised when they found out that the
same character would be played by actor
Toby anwemere in the second it seems
that our means departure was a result of
some kind of behind-the-scenes conflict
with executive producer and director
Lana Wachowski apparently the two began
clashing during table reads for season 2
in Berlin rather than working out their
differences before the cameras began
rolling a meeting with chelski continued
to butt heads when filming for new
episodes began in India as a result a
meme was abruptly replaced by a new
actor it's a mystery as to what actually
caused the tensions between Amin and
Wachowski perhaps it was merely creative
differences and disagreements about the
storyline for a means character in
season two maybe a meeting with chelski
didn't get along on a personal level and
their strange relationship was beginning
to affect the atmosphere on set whatever
the reason fans may never get a straight
answer
Paul Campbell played Billy kikea on the
2004 series Battlestar Galactica for two
years his character served as a personal
assistant to president Laura Roslyn but
Campbell did not sign an official
contract with the show and while he was
working on Battlestar Galactica he was
still open to new opportunities at the
beginning of season 2 he landed a role
in a new pilot which took him away from
filming for a few episodes when said
pilot didn't work out he would turn to
Battlestar Galactica but his appearances
on the show became sporadic and the
showrunners were getting frustrated with
his absences this resulted in his cards
are being killed off Campbell explained
in a 2006 interview with the Sci-Fi
world so after that they kind of gave me
the ultimatum and said sign a contract
for five years or we kind of need to go
our separate ways and I kind of put it
off and put it off then eventually they
just said look we can tell you're not
really committed to the show and we
can't write storylines so we've decided
to kill the character
[Music]
thank you